Speaker 1: Let's go next to Chuck from
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania. Chuck, welcome
to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: What's going on? David,
can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can.
Speaker 4: Not really a question. Just kind of
giving you guys an update from PR here since the
this important Senate race coming up here and
supernatural. Yeah. Yeah well so yeah I live I
don't actually live in Pittsburgh. I live south of
Pittsburgh about an hour, but it's like really the
only notable thing. So that's why I put that.
But I live in Fayette County and it's pretty,
pretty red here. But I mean, it's just it's pretty
disgusting when I drive around, like everybody's
got all these mastriano signs in there. So it's
got me a little worried. The only thing I you guys
or you cover, like, the, uh, the polling.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's looking
pretty good right now for SHAPIRO.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's looking good, too. That's.
That's got my hopes up. I know that, like, when
I drive around, like I said, it gets me a little
worried just because, you know, I live in, like,
a red area, so that's all I see. Yeah, but another
thing, I was at the Washington County Fair,
which is actually the county to the left of me.
Speaker 1: And we say to the
West, Is that what you mean?
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah, to the west or
left. If you were like looking on a map.
Speaker 1: I didn't know if you meant
like left the way you're sitting
right now or something like that.
Speaker 4: Oh, no. Okay. Uh, but
as we were leaving the fair and again, I'm not
a big, fair person, I just kind of went because
I don't know. I haven't been in a while and we
are leaving and we're walking back to through
this like field to our car and like this family
is walking out and they got like three kids and
they're all can't remember if they were I think
they were just waving either American flags or
like Doug Mastriano flags or something,
but their kids were chanting F JB.
Speaker 2: And it was just a very.
Speaker 4: Very disturbing
sight to see. Like, how.
Speaker 1: Old were the kids?
Speaker 4: Oh, probably like nine.
Speaker 1: Oh. Oh, my goodness.
Speaker 4: Yeah. It was like very cultish,
but it was pretty disgusting. And then
another thing real quick is like where
I live, I actually fly an American flag
off my house just to kind of because like, I
feel like a lot of Republican like, you know,
if you're not a Trump or if you don't support
the U.S.. Or like, you know, fly a U.S. flag,
I feel like you're like looked at as like a demon.
Speaker 1: It's stigmatized.
Speaker 4: Republican. Yeah. So, yeah, I got in
my house to maybe, you know, not get my house
shot up or something by an angry Republican.
Speaker 1: That's not that. I mean, you know,
the man who's Jewish, progressive but lives in
upstate New York, he wears flannels and grows
a big beard. I try to blend in, so I understand.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I go there. I don't grow a beard
for that reason. I actually just enjoy a beard.
But yeah, it actually does help fit in. I guess.
Speaker 1: It certainly does. All
right, my friend, thank you so much
for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Yep. No worries.
Speaker 1: All right. Interesting calls
today from all over the place. I'm I'm
liking it. Let's see, where do we want to
go next? How about let's go to Lahav from
Greensborough. Lahav, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: Okay. I want to play a quick fire game.
Speaker 1: We're going to
play a game now, you and I.
Speaker 2: Yes. I list a politician
and I want you to say the first word
you think of to describe them.
Speaker 1: Okay, let's try it.
Speaker 2: Elizabeth Warren.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. Buttoned up.
Speaker 2: Kirsten Cinema.
Speaker 1: Confused?
Speaker 2: butI judge.
Speaker 1:
Vicious.
Speaker 2: Jamaal Bowman I don't know enough.
Speaker 1: About him to
really comment with one word.
Speaker 2: Mitt Romney.
Speaker 1: Timid.
Speaker 2:
Um, let's see. Steve Scalise.
Speaker 1: Pathetic.
Speaker 2: Gretchen Whitmer.
Speaker 1: Oh, man. Gretchen Whitmer. Milquetoast.
Speaker 2: I'm.
Speaker 1: AOC passionate.
Speaker 2: Jill Stein.
Speaker 1: Um. Very nice, I guess.
Speaker 2: Jeb Bush.
Speaker 1: Um, Jeb Bush. Very nice.
How many more of these are there, by the way? Oh,
I'm sorry. Did you see Jill Stein? I thought you
said Jill Biden. Hold on. Jill Stein.
Speaker 2: Jill Stein.
Speaker 1: Cuckoo.
Speaker 2: Yeah. That's
better. Okay. Tulsi Gabbard.
Speaker 1: Despicable.
Speaker 2: Okay. And let's see here.
Speaker 1: Let's let's let's let's leave it
there. I think that's good. That's a lot. I don't
know that I have too many of these left in me.
Speaker 2: Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you
very much for the call. Appreciate it. By the way,
milk toast is m i l q u e for everybody who now is
looking that up. But it's not like milk. Milk like
from cereal and milk. All right, everybody, let's
take a very quick break, but we're still going to
take calls after the break. So if you're holding
to chat with me, hold on just a little longer
and I will hopefully get to you. Quick break